*звук вибуху*
Вони підривають перешкоди
Наводять мости – лише за кілька хвилин
Це – солдати Бундесверу на навчаннях НАТО
Trident Juncture
Втім, чи подібні навички взагалі потрібні
в часи гібридної війни та кібер-атак?
Зрештою після кризи в Україні ми побачили
що важливіше перейти від операцій зі стабілізації
до високоінтенсивних бойових дій
Це те, що ми бачимо
Ми зацікавлені в маневрах більших формувань
і важкого озброєння
Цього не робили останні 10 років
Табір Бундесверу розташований далеко від російського кордону
посеред норвезької тундри
10 тисяч німців тренуються разом із військовими
з Франції, Нідерландів, Бельгії та Латвії
Це тест на міцність і для країни-господарки – Норвегії.
Понад 50 тисяч військових із 31 держави
необхідно нагодувати й розселити
Полковник Кварвінг 6 років готував ці навчання
У середмісті Трондхайма нині він спостерігає за всіма операціями
Поки – всім задоволений
Приємно бачити, що все дійсно працює
Звісно, з добрими союзниками
а ще враховуючи, що США розмістили своє озброєння в Норвегії на регулярній основі
Гадаю, це ознака того, що Альянс присутній там,
де він потрібен
Але сподіваюсь, що в реальному житті нам усе це не знадобиться
Населення Норвегії також – «за» ці навчання.
Підтримка НАТО в країні – найбільша серед держав-членів Альянсу
І це не лише через спільний із Росією кордон
Ми не боїмося війни. Не тепер
Але в світі стільки всього стається, що ти ніколи не знаєш
Так що Альянс для нас дуже важливий
Ну, я думаю, Росія останніми роками перетворилась на велику загрозу
і ми маємо показати свою міць
У світі тривають війни
і я знаю, що це могло статися й тут.
Але я про це не думаю
Чимало операцій проводяться подалі від очей громадян
як-от випробування систем дистанційного керування зброєю
або самокерованих бойових машин
або дронів-шпигунів
Тож традиційні методи ведення війни
вже не потрібні?
Всі ці якості мають бути двостронніми
тобто війська можуть на них покладатися
але мають вміти обходитися без них
Всі ці системи можна вивести з ладу
або знищити, або захопити
Так що військовим треба залишатися гнучкими
І саме тому НАТО і далі покладається
на танки і піхоту
Тут, у холодному норвезькому кліматі